Let's talk about Galician nationalism,
calea raison d'être of Galician nationalist campaign,
according to text by Vicente rischio published in oano
1,920,
5 songos motives that raised to 1 Galician nationalism.
Number 1,
Osastigo
to see that the laws that were being enacted
did not meet the needs
and the conveniences of other lands.
Number 2,
the huge problems that Prague Lisa or sex 2 face,
mass immigration or country in labor,
number 3,
to the death of 1 Galician industry
that antano was strong,
number 4,
or poor use of our natural resources,
including 1 wrong anesiography treatment,
devastated mountains,
etc.
number 5,
or is that cement of Galician culture,
those included in nosafala,
Nosa music or Nosa,
to our traditions.
Go to me,
the question for you is,
coities that as of today
are still in force
according to all some of these problems,
I open debate,
I read it to you in Calviño's comments.